hello everybody
my name is marky player and welcome back
to
three scary games
the end is near the end
is near the end is near
the end is
i suppose you've made it to the wrong
place there is nothing here
all right let's go into the nothing into
the absolute dick
diddly hello hi
hello
huh
is this arrow pointing me towards the
nothingness that is in wherever the hell
i'm not
i'm nowhere and everywhere and well
that's weird
hello
what what
why is it happening i've never been
assaulted like this
before my senses are
oh there's nothing i made it
there was nothing wait no what's
happening
what is happening there was nothing here
what
why what are you doing what are you
doing
what do you mean what do you mean was
what do you mean what do you mean
[Music]
what do you mean oh no
oh no oh no
oh what
why
there was nothing here all along
that's weird
they they they made it
who's they there was nothing there
are you man what are you talking about
what are you talking about what are you
talking about
what are you talking about what are you
talking what happened to my painting a
lovely doc
oh oh what's wrong with you
you okay who got a headache
in the bath what is in the bathroom
nothing oh i'm coming in there
i'm coming in there now
all right there was nothing there
find a key oh there it is
oh this is just about
you know you're right about that or are
you
oh yeah that's oh
[Music]
okay all right okay
[Music]
what are you doing to me why are you
doing this to me
down wait down down go back down
what did you just start the same thing
over again
full on me twi i'm going
full on you fool me on you
you made us
there's something here where
here right here
oh oh oh no oh
no oh boy my favorite tv show but
i'm distracted by the horror oh
no oh hi hi
there oh aren't you cute
oh peekaboo
how are you peekaboo come on oh key
hi uh this old trick
okay all right okay whatever you say
oh oh um well i wish i could go up but i
can't
i guess there's something here after all
oh i still don't like you
something oh no god
hi buds have a locked okay
oh go back okay all right um
okay
okay oh
what is what is you what are you okay
oh oh okay
oh darkness i am in the dark i can't
it's very dark oh six six six perfect
e hello oh
no i'm sorry wrong room i
apologize for disturbing you
yeah you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
leave
just see it have a good have a good day
okay i can't see anything it's so dark
i can't see if you can't see now then i
can't see nothing staff only hello
i'm staff okay i swear i was looking at
that
oh oh
[Music]
that was good that was one of those
games where i saw the thumbnail and i
was like
oh that would that might be good that
might be good so i'm just about an open
doorway very scary
very scary okay moving on
it's good it's good
welcome to lights camera slaughter the
demo
i don't know if this is supposed to be a
tv show where we're going to be
murdering people
or it's just recording murders as they
happen
which is very rare and hard to do well
it doesn't make for good tv you're an
intern working on the new movie camp of
the cannibals directed by
johnny slash love that a film
anticipated by thousands for its guts
gore and purity johnny is well known for
his other movies such as
blood in the walls flesh eaters and
murder in the city one two and three
scene 32 take four the cannibal bites
back
okay i should start finding drew and
cynthia
it's getting real dark oh so is this the
movie or is this us making the movie
is this us filming the movie is this
like making a found footage type thing
my car my piece of [ __ ] car had to drive
60 miles to get here
i ain't leaving now yeah 60 miles i
never leave that behind it says we've
gone to look for a spot to sleep we
should be done when you set here if you
know
what i mean wink wink
wink wink they're gonna murder each
other this drew's car he must be
railing cynthia or getting stoned i
better
join them
maybe it's not murder hello no i don't
know any of these other cars
who cares screw them terrible cars
awful they do encapsulate the 80s so i
got to give it that
what's that smell oh i don't want to
know what that smell is
i really don't want to know what that
smell is well i'm going to walk away
from that and
pretend it never happened because as far
as i'm concerned it did not
what is happening hello
okay i'll bench some old bench looks
like it's been here a while
yeah it's kind of how benches work
someone just puts them down and they
just
stay there hopefully well seems like a
whole lot of nothing
i don't hear the sounds of ecstasy and
or
death in the immediate vicinity so i'm
assuming everything's
quieted down my girls
hello what just happened
what is happening what is happening
and why i'm gonna assume nothing until
i'm proven otherwise
there's nothing lurking behind me
there's nothing off to the sides of my
vision
there's no huge clawed big tooth
monstrosity coming down the way
samantha ain't getting railed looks
abandoned
hmm i don't know why they would oh blood
oh yeah
this is getting weird now now you know
when i see a giant puddle of blood
on the ground my first instinct isn't to
go
oh it's getting weird now oh this is
weird huh how'd this blood get here hmm
this
is strange a puzzle's a foot there's
really only one way that a large amount
of blood gets on the ground
and uh well i mean you could guess what
it is
lexian show them a demonstration unless
that's too hard to animate
and then don't don't you dare
unless you want to and in that case who
am i to stop your creativity
i'm not an animator i don't know how bad
or hard that is to do
i appreciate you do what you want
anyway ah they gotta be here but i don't
hear them
i don't hear the siren song of samantha
getting railed
weird hello
are people even camping where are they
what's that smell
oh god no well
there's room
he's dead holy [ __ ] the first time
why oh my god oh holy
[ __ ]
jiminy my christmas you still back there
buddy
oh
i've been got
the cannibal is bitten back
i like that i like that they did say
that this was just a demo
that got me that really got me but i did
like that that was very good
all right moving on
this one's called do not take your eyes
away from the red fridge
don't know why you're looking at me
buddy my red fridge do you
authors these people play
so am i actually not supposed to take my
eyes don't look away
that's a little concerning why are you
trying to do that that's not me looking
away
for some oh hey for some reason the game
wants me to look away from the red
fridge
i am not always keep doing that
do not take your eyes away from the red
fridge well i wasn't planning on it
um i know your weak spot what weak spot
is that you talking to me here is that
me talking to you because if that's you
talking to me then you wrote these
messages and you're telling me not to
look away from the red fridge
so that's exactly what you want me to do
and if that's the case then
it's maybe not something i should do if
i find out his name i'll be able to
leave
oh the fridge's name the name of the
fridge this fridge has a name
what a simplistic concept okay i'm just
gonna
it wants me to look at it that's what
are you doing something that's what i
was saying it it wants me to look at it
why does it want me to look at it at it
why would it well that's no good
what are you doing it won't let you out
you're getting closer to me oh no no no
no
oh no no no no no okay
it's been nine hours the fridge is not
responding
oh no no no no i will definitely figure
out how to help
lori i don't know who laurie is eyes
you son of a [ __ ] need to back up
right now i'm warning you i'm a very
dangerous person when i'm cornered
dolly what happened to you no he fell
forward
dolly back up oh my god
no little princess
turn away does it feel like it's going
to kill me yep i get that feeling
oop why it is definitely closer
is it closer am i crazy it feels like
it's closer
huh
hlp beautiful that's not how you spell
that
[Music]
what was that sleepy
oh wait so if i play the doll
oh i can look away
okay so if i play the doll i can look
away from it now i just
now it is clear i lost my fridge magnet
letters
what why
oh
his name is the fridge his name's
the fridge you think you're
you won i hope she is still
something g g
f seems like lori is talking to me but i
can't understand what she's saying
yeah i get that the sun rose twice
already
oh you're so close okay the fridge has
understood what i'm trying to do
what is it that i'm trying to do there's
a demon in the fridge this is unhelpful
oh i
oh oh e i have to find the letters
but i gotta find d because i need to
spell
out the fridge i don't see d
anywhere i don't think d exists e but no
d
i got r g f e
i but no d i need d one hour later okay
i'm gonna look away from the fridge ah
don't kill me
well i mean kill me
oh my god you are closer
you all right there buddy well i'm glad
that i wasn't crazy because i definitely
that thing definitely is getting closer
i'm just going
[Music]
wake up oh i can't wake up wake up oh my
god
all right just killed me already because
there's g
i can't even get g things must have
gotten knocked around oh hi
how are you doing good come on kill me
already
oh my god
well there you go ah i looked away from
the red fridge
let me try that again just because i
feel like things got tossed around a bit
because there's this stack of boxes but
something underneath
oh see it seems to be mad at me for some
reason
i don't know is there some way that i
move these
i'm at a complete loss all right all
right i'm stuck
i don't know man i wish i knew
apparently i don't know
[Music]
i have to press and hold the things
which is not the most intuitive thing
i've ever experienced
and i only found that out by going to
the the other place which
you know whatever but i can click and
drag
anything ah
i still don't know where d is but i'm
guessing it it'll
reveal itself when i move things out of
the way
oh my god it was under the oh my god
gotcha
take that you big dumb dummy ow
am i free i'm free apparently i've done
it okay
so started out wonderful i feel like it
would have been so much better
if that fridge was way more threatening
i could look away from that thing
for a minute that's a long time
i like the mechanic of using the doll to
put it to sleep but maybe like random
timer on the doll for
not knowing when it's going to cut out
and then very quickly like
it gets really close to you that would
have been scarier but still
i love the premise it's an interesting
premise so
good but moving on
oh hey buddy this is lost room
i wonder if i'm gonna be locked in a
lost room with you
i have a funny feeling then maybe yes
son
we're gone don't forget to collect toys
before we arrive
good mom i understand you understood you
have a good time
what conversation was that
it looked like english it did not sound
like english
hey bunny book
batar i can't do nothing about it i can
do
nothing about it i refuse to do anything
about that
i can do something about that but i
can't do something about this
strange bizarre
all right home to myself uh
voltage surges you need to take matches
or a candle letter
i'm sorry voltage surges
in my eyeballs
from where my father forbids me to come
here in his absence
if father forbids it then i shall never
try
father has forbade it it has been
forbidden
and i shall not deviate from his plan
candle
candle no can't do anything about that
probably because i don't have matches
i have nothing to do there i too often
look at a room
with disdain and disgust what kind of
how
what kind of layout is this [ __ ]
first thing i like when i come home from
a long day's work is the long
ominous hallway of doom that's the stuff
for me
please yeah oh
you see there's a bit of a geometrical
problem here there's some empty space
not being taken up by this double bath
bathroom
one sink two bath one toilet
what this is the scariest thing i've
seen in a horror game that bathroom is
terrifying
it makes no sense that must be the lost
room
all right so i gotta find a flashlight
or match it or something there we go
there we go lighter chunk
can i not can i not ah whatever
well i got this thing i feel good about
it i feel good about myself actually
tv broke yesterday why did it broke
yesterday
oh i pick up a toy right uh that's what
mom told me i got to pick up
my toys or these i'm very tall for these
toys
there is everything is done i'll go
watch tv
but it was broke since yesterday how
about i go my room
my room tv oh
oh jesus my parents come back
without keys
yeah yes
who's there hmm
weird well good gosh screw you
apparently the children are indulging
stop indulging my father has forbade
indulgence
you shall not indulge in my father's
absence i will have none of it all right
what do i do now
the children did oh father has forbade
this action
those damn children are indulging
well this is strange anyone indulging in
here
only my father was allowed to do so
oh no oh [ __ ] no electricity now i have
to go down to the basement
yeah this hell hole has a basement am i
supposed to be able to light
anything literally anything i can't see
you see how this is a problem i don't
have any idea where i am
was i supposed to light things before
because i didn't just wandering in the
darkness
don't mind me can't even figure out how
to turn a lighter
l l l is the l
also what is in this hell
this is damn children they could just
stop indulging
for one second
so what was the scream all about huh
well no candles in the bathroom see this
bathroom makes no sense
it's utterly terrifying there's no
candles in
never mind i'm sorry excuse me
a father are you oh i swear
no one was indulging i didn't mean to go
in your room i know you forbade it
but i couldn't help myself i thought
there was the indulgence of
children i had to put a stop to it
somehow
that's the basement oh god
i forbid that from ever happening again
i forbid
i for a cement mixer you know
i've seen a lot i need to keep why
i'm not done here let me do my bit
anyway
basement smart mixer a little weird just
gonna say a wheelbarrow why
where's your wheelbarrow flashlight wow
all right there's no fuse box i guess i
guess i don't fix the power in the
basement why did i want to come to the
basement
who might ask oh that's a problem
who might ask questions a stack of five
tires why
five five tires five doesn't make sense
how do i get out of here do i gotta blow
myself up
and blow this house sky high you know
that would be me in any horror movie if
there's a situation where
you know the cliche thing like blow it
we're all dead blow it
you know and there's a bomb and you blow
it i would blow what what i'm
gonna father
how that goes i can't i do not feel like
that was supposed to happen
let me double check but i'm pretty sure
that probably was wrong
okay so that definitely wasn't the end
okay that 100
was not the end i didn't see what the
end was i don't know spoil myself
so let's try it again what if i just
leave
let me out all right get ready for jump
scare city
okay thank you all right
so there's supposedly oh a key ah
i need a key that's right i ignored that
because i couldn't tell what the hell it
was saying
i got a key i'm going back to here
i know there's something up with this
thing oh whoa
what the hell it moved oh
that's weird to have in my parents
boudoir
why what's that oh hi where the hell uh
um how do i uh but
but the thing is about this situation
is um uh uh but where could i lose
oh my oh
okay maybe i could circle around in the
basement but oh
boy now you know what this ain't gonna
work this ain't gonna do the stuff ah
don't get me i'm fine i made it around i
guess i could have circled around the tv
that would have made a lot more sense
and whatever the hell i did
okay i understand why this zone was
forbidden this was forbade for good
reasons
oh i'm going down it's an elevator
i suspected that my father was secretly
elevating things
uh explains the cement mixture and
numerous odd numbered wheels
hi why you die
i gotcha you thought but you thought
wrong
[ __ ] there's more toilets probably even
more bathtubs
and even number of bathtubs odd number
of toilets assuming we continued
nothing makes sense children indulging
father forbading
that's pretty good i mean obviously it
was run through google translate or
something like that
but still has some good elements to it
that one jump scare
got me i don't want them scared got me
holy [ __ ] it did
but i like that
thank you so much for watching this
three
scary games video
the end is here your hand
is here your end is
[Music]
you